cette photo en fait elle a deux versions
la version officielle on va dire bah
c'est comme vous le voyez une belle
histoire entre un ours et un loup même
le photographe qui a pris cette photo il
parle de l'histoire de Roméo et Juliette
mais en fait dans la nature ça se passe
pas du tout comme ça et une scène comme
celle-ci B en fait ça existe pas c'est
pas possible de prendre ça en photo pour
réaliser une photo comme ça bah faut
forcément tricher et donc c'est ce qu'on
a essayé de raconter dans l'enquête
qu'on vient de publier sur reporter la
première alerte qu'on a a reçu c'était
une alerte qu'on a reçu par mail donc
d'un naturaliste qui faisait une étude
en Finlande et qui avait assisté à tout
ça et donc petit à petit ensuite on a
essayé de vérifier cette information de
croiser les sources et donc on a
contacté plein de photographes
animaliers qui petit à petit ont pu nous
parler de ces pratiques on a même trouvé
une vidéo sur Youtube en fait c'est un
photographe amateur euh qui est allé
dans ces affus exactement dans les affus
don dont on parle dans l'article et donc
on se rend compte que il y a tout plein
de cabanes à igné les unes les autres
c'est une petite industrie c'est juste
un hôtel avec la vue sur des prédateurs
qui ont quitté leur forêt qui ont quitté
leur espace naturel pour venir dévorer
la nourriture que l'homme leur a apporté
et a mis sur le sous leur nez donc en
fait ils se mettent dans ses cabanes et
après il y a un employé du site en fait
tout simplement qui arrive avec une
motau neige il a dans sa remorque des
carcasses de cochon des trucs énormes et
en fait il va les installer par terre
pile dans l'axe des photographes il va
les accrocher un arbre de manière à ce
que les prédateurs donc les ours les
loups les gloutons qu'on trouve là-bas
se barre pas avec la carcasse et puis en
plus de ça ils vont ajouter des
croquettes pour chien du saumon enfin
plein de nourriture que que les ces
animaux ne trouveraient pas du tout dans
la nature et donc ça va attirer plein
d'ours plein de loups plein d'animaux et
sur ces scènes bah on voit clairement
que les ours et les loups se retrouvent
en contact euh ce bagarre pour de la
nourriture donc on pourrait se dire bon
ben voilà c'est c'est comme ça c'est pas
très grave mais en fait c'est assez
grave euh déjà pour les animaux tout
simplement il y a plusieurs effets
collatéraux euh le premier ça va être la
propagation de maladie euh mais aussi la
l'augmentation du nombre de combats et
puis si par exemple une une maman ours
se ramène avec ses petits euh et qu'elle
croise à cet endroit-là un Mâ bah en
fait ça peut tout simplement provoquer
des infanticides les mâs peuvent s'en
prendre au petit et en plus de ça euh
bah tout simplement un petit ourson ou
un petit loup euh qui vient et qui
apprend que on peut trouver du saumon ou
que le saumon pousse dans les prairies
et ben une fois que il va quitter sa
mère et donc qu'il va aller conquérir un
nouveau territoire si dans ce nouveau
territoire il y a pas cette source de
nourriture artificielle bah il va pas
comprendre il va pas savoir que le
saumon il faut aller le chercher dans la
rivière que le cochon bah il va pas en
trouver dans la nature et que les
croquettes de chien non plus cette photo
elle est hyper intéressante parce que
c'est la photo qu'on prendrait si on
voulait pas cacher la vérité c'est la
photo pure de ce qui se passe de ce que
voit les les photographes et donc c'est
un ours qui a les deux pieds sur la tête
d'un cochon et donc en fait cette photo
personne n'a envie de l'avir personne
n'a envie de d'aller liker une photo
comme ça sur Instagram après cette
pratique de de l'apâage ou du
nourrissage des prédateurs c'est pas la
seule il y a aussi plein d'autres
pratiques il y a des fermes à lynx dans
les pays d'Europe de l'Est il y a des
fermes à Puma aux États-Unis euh des
fermes à rapace c'est bah tout
simplement des sortes de zo euh mais qui
vont pas forcément être ouverts au
public et par contre les animaux sont
dressés euh pour prendre la pause euh
sous l'œil des photographes qui ont plus
que plus qu'à cliquer euh après il y a
plein d'autres supercheries il y a aussi
en Asie du Sud-Est il y a beaucoup de
photos de grenouilles notamment des
grenouilles très colorées super belles
qu'on peut retrouver assez souvent sur
Instagram qui vont prendre des positions
euh qui nous paraissent complètement
exubérantes par exemple qui va s'abriter
sous un champignon euh qui va se mettre
à cheval sur un autre insecte et en fait
ces images faut vraiment faire attention
parce que derrière ce que nous on voit
sur insta les photographes congèlent ces
petites grenouilles et une fois qu'elles
sont soit complètement endormies soit
même morte ils vont les ressortir des
congélateurs les
positionner dans dans les positions que
qu'ils veulent et ensuite pouvoir
prendre des photos justement qu'on qu'on
arriverait jamais à prendre dans la
nature et ils font pareil aussi avec les
souris ou les papillons et parfois même
il passe des fils de fer dans les
membres de ces animaux pour les mettre
dans la position sont désiré et ensuite
pouvoir prendre leur photos et ensuite
il y a un photographe brésilien qui a
remporté le prix le plus prestigieux de
la photographie
animalière en prenant une photo de
fourmilier et en fait on s'est rendu
compte plusieurs mois après une fois
qu'on lui avait donné le titre que cette
photo tout simplement ben c'était la
photo d'un fourmilier qui était empaillé
cette photo elle est elle est
intéressante aussi c'est la photo d'un
martin pêcheur qui est en train de
plonger dans l'eau pour essayer
d'attraper un poisson et donc donc cette
photo faut pas se tromper c'est c'est
des photos qui ont été réalisées par un
photographe écossais il a passé 4200 he
dans son affu a essayé de prendre la
photo du martin pêcheur qui est sur le
point d'entrer dans l'eau sans aucune AC
la boussure c'est la photo parfaite et
donc derrière cette photo est devenue
tellement célèbre que pour essayer de la
reproduire ben il y a plein d'autres
photographes beaucoup moins scrupuleux
qui eux se sont dit bah comment faire ça
un peu plus rapidement comment faire ça
sans y passer 6 ans de ma vie et ben je
vais installer un aquarium à la surface
de l'eau avec plein de poissons comme ça
ça va attirer les Martin pêcheurs il y
en a beaucoup plus qui vont venir et
donc j'aurai ma photo beaucoup plus
rapidement sauf que du coup c'est quoi
le problème derrière c'est que le martin
pêcheur au moment d'entrer dans l'eau il
va se briser le bec contre la la glace
la vitre de l'aquarium et il va
instantanément s'écraser et mourir et
donc voilà pour une photo ce qu'on est
capable de faire pour une photo que
qu'on va ensuite croiser sur Instagram
où on va se dire waouh c'est magnifique
le mec a dû passer des he à prendre
cette photo bah non tout simplement il a
installé son aquarium et il a tué un
animal c'est pas tous les photographes
qui font ça c'est en milieu il y a il y
a une certaines éthique comment ça
réagit en fait en fait à la publication
de l'article comme je vous disais j'ai
reçu beaucoup de messages de photograp
professionnel beaucoup de photographes
même quasiment tous les photographes en
tout cas ceux qui travaillent sur ces
espèces là savent que ça existe mais ils
osaient pas le dire parce que Ben comme
c'est un milieu fermé c'est un peu
compliqué de se mettre à dos tel ou tel
photographe ou tel ou tel FA festival et
du coup en fait personne n'osait trop en
parler mais une fois qu'on a publié
cette enquête euh déjà ça a pas été
évident de trouver des témoignage parce
que bah justement les photographes
étaient assez réticents à parler de tout
ça mais par contre une fois que
l'enquête a été publiée j'ai reçu
beaucoup de message de photographe
professionnel qui me disait mais merci
en fait d'avoir levé le masque un petit
peu sur toutes ces pratiques parce que
ça fait des années que ça dure ça fait
des années que ça a créé une concurrence
déloyale pour nous qui devons passé des
mois dans la nature pour espérer ramener
une ou deux photos et donc ils étaient
vraiment soulagés ça rappelle aussi à
quel point d'autres photographes euh ont
des pratiques beaucoup plus éthiques euh
beaucoup plus dans le respect de la
nature et en fait c'est ça l'essence
même du métier de photographe animalier
c'est de respecter le vivant c'est de de
respecter l'environnement dans lequel on
est et donc ces photographes là m'ont
raconté comment eux travailler et donc
bah par exemple une des premières règles
qu'on apprend en photo ie animalière
c'est d'arriver avant les animaux de
s'immobiliser dans un affu donc
c'est-à-dire de se cacher dans la nature
complètement et de repartir qu'une fois
que l'animal est parti autrement dit
l'animal il voit même pas qu'on est là
il arrive il sait pas qu'on est là il
repart il sait toujours pas qu'on est là
et c'est ça faire de la photographie
animalière c'est ne pas déranger les
animaux et et les laisser vivre
tranquillement leur vie dans leur milieu
[Musique]
naturel